[Music]
welcome back to our next episode of
what's up prof
hello walter good day how are you doing
today
well i'm doing good it's been a
interesting week yes very yeah it took a
while to get here and now we can start
talking about the election again
absolutely i'll open with a word of
prayer
our heavenly father we thank you that we
can gather again
and have discussions lord we are in
serious times and we need discernment in
that
therefore we ask that you bless us with
the holy spirit's
enlightenment and also in our discussion
in jesus name amen
well it's been a very tumultuous
election
and a very important one yes
and uh i recall having said in a
previous what's up
that uh it doesn't really matter who
wins right
correct and uh also
we said that the philosophy of the biden
cam
is more in line with the social doctrine
of the roman catholic church
yes which is uh according to the latest
encyclical of the pope
something that he really once
implemented in the world
yes and then you have of course the
the hopes of the prophets out there
and the so-called q anons out there
for a final draining of the swamp
yes and it seems as though
the swamp is winning it does
and there are some painful uh
things happening in the world out there
but
to us we are observers right correct
we are observing it and putting it into
a prophetic context
now what i find fascinating
is that all along we've said there must
be a
synthesis you have a
thesis you have an antithesis
and then you must have a synthesis
yes now how do you get these two sides
together well the idea is to separate
them as far as possible from each other
create the conflict
and then call for the healing which will
require a synthesis that means that
the far left and the far right agendas
will have to be dropped
and there will have to be a compromise
situation
yes now in this election it's not even
sure whether
biden has actually won the courts will
probably still decide that
correct and it's also not sure who
controls the senate
yes at the moment it's
a neck and neck with the republicans
controlling two more senate seats than
the
democrats yes but they can still pick up
some so
it could become an even game
so the interesting thing is even if
biden
is eventually declared the president of
the united states or although he has
declared himself that already
then how much power will he actually
have
if yeah if the if the republicans get
the senate
that's right and then he will have to
rule
and pass legislation by
careful compromise correct now what is
that isn't that sensitive
this is that synthesis right
but we need some very strong ideas on
both sides
yes and somehow these must be married
so let's have a look at uh what happened
in this election yes and we've
we've also concentrated a lot in the
previous episodes
on the trump side of what you've been
just mentioned yes
so now we're also going to look a little
bit on the biden side yes
to see where this is aiding yes so we
also had this interesting
uh comparison about king of the north
philosophy king of the south philosophy
and we said that both sides actually
contain elements of king of the north
correct
and king of the south although the biden
camp contains
more of the south than king of the north
philosophy but there could be a major
swing especially if there's a synthesis
right
so how much does religion have to do
with this election and let's just say it
straight out
everything it's actually
i think it's the first in in history
where there's so much about this right
so let's have a look at some of the
issues uh we have a video here
of biden's speech after he
claimed that he had won the elections we
have to be careful how we phrase these
yeah
because you cannot say he won the
election
nothing yeah finalized yet all right
so let's look at that
the bible tells us to everything there
is a season
a time to build a time to reap and a
time to sow
and a time to heal this is the time to
heal in america
we have an opportunity to defeat despair
to build a nation of prosperity and
purpose
we can do it i know we can i've long
talked about the battle for the soul of
america
we must restore the soul of america
our nation is shaped by the constant
battle
between our better angels and our
darkest impulses
and what presidents say in this battle
matters
it's time for our better angels to
prevail
tonight the whole world is watching
america
and i believe at our best america is a
beacon
for the globe we will not leave we will
lead not only by the example of our
power
but by the power of our example folks
in the last days of the campaign i began
thinking about a hymn
that means a lot to me and my family
particularly my deceased son bo
it captures the faith that sustains me
which i believe sustains america and i
hope
and i hope it can provide some comfort
and solace the 230
million thousand americans who've lost a
loved one to this terrible virus this
year
my heart goes out to each and every one
of you hopefully this hymn gives you
solace as well it goes like this
and he will raise you up on eagle's
wings
bear you on the breath of dawn and make
you just sign like the sun
and hold you in the palm of his hand
and now together on eagle's wings we
embark on the work
that god and history have called upon us
to do
with full hearts and steady hands
with faith in america in each other with
love of country
a thirst for justice let us be the
nation that we know we can be
a nation united a nation strengthened a
nation healed
the united states of america ladies and
gentlemen
there's never never been anything we've
tried we've not been able to do
so remember as my grandpa our grandpappy
said when i walked out of his home
when i was a kid up in scranton he said
joey keep the faith
and our grandmother when she was alive
she yelled no joey spread it
spread the faith god love you all may
god bless america
and may god protect our church thank you
thank you thank you
tell me my friend was that a political
speech
or was that a religious speech it was
quite religious
it started off with god it talked about
spreading the faith
and it talked about the church hinted
off with
may god protect the church which church
well he's a
roman catholic so i don't think we have
to think too far
we don't have to think too much about
that right
but nevertheless it was a religious
speech
and that was the king of the north
element coming through there
yeah now it's still in dispute as to
whether he will be the president
but if he is that is a very interesting
introduction yes now there are many
things
that seem to be troubling
and many have voiced their concerns even
democrats have voiced their concerns
and i think we should listen to one or
two of those
and eventually we'll try and put it all
together right
correct now this video
is about irregularities
that seem to be coming to the fore and
this is a democrat
vernon jones who is talking about these
issues
let's listen to what he has to say
let me be frank and earnest
there's a dead cat on the end of this
line
and it's thinking it's thinking with
fraud
distinct with lack of transparency
is thinking with non-accountability
and is thinking with those who call
themselves
wanting to have fair elections it's
thinking with their absence
is fair fight if you're standing for
people's rights
and their right to vote and every vote
is counted every legal vote is counted
where is fair fight
i'll tell you where fair fight is fair
fight to that crowd is fair
when their man is stealing the election
that's when it's fair to them
[Applause]
as a member of the georgia general
assembly 12-year member
it is my duty to speak up for every
georgian
when their vote is not being counted
accurately
and when there's all this type of
illegal
irregularities taking place that's what
i like about donald trump
he travels with a set of twins one name
accountability
and the other one named transparency
that's what i like about him
[Applause]
i've had democrats republicans black
white
gave the whole cross across the whole
state of georgia
matter of fact across this country
saying what is going on in georgia
i may not agree with your candidate
vernon but if they take my vote if they
take your vote away from you they're
taking my vote away from me
that's the american spirit
and what i see happen this is a sham
this is a sham
and it's disgraceful
so what do you think about that
interesting to say the least
it shows you that there's some
on biden's camp even that thinks it's uh
there's something wrong there's
something fishy a dead cat
well be that as it may uh whether this
is real or whether this is not real is
actually irrelevant the outcome is
what's going to happen
and if you believe like i do that god is
ultimately in control of all things
then whether it is fair or whether it is
not fair
it is still within god's permissive
world right correct
and prophecy will be and prophecy will
be fulfilled irrespective
of whether it's fair or whether it's not
fair that's not for us to judge
now this is an article from fox news
and it says that falsely said trump is
asking for trouble with potential
super spreader rallies but he's silent
on biden's celebrations
now we've had a lot to say on foreseeing
the past
and the relationship between trump and
fawcy
and whether that is all part of the
hegelian dialectic
or not is irrelevant some people will
say we're talking conspiracy theories
but they must enjoy themselves we are
talking
news exactly we're just looking at what
the news has to say
but it is interesting that foresee seems
to be
uh siding somewhat with the biden camp
right yeah
well he's quite silent when it comes to
the byron camp and quite outspoken when
it comes to
the trump campaign but then we know that
those who are influenced by jesuit
philosophy or the jesuits themselves
they can easily switch sides because the
real side that matters
is the one that they serve exactly he
is silent when it comes to the biden
celebrations also without mosques
and the other celebrations is rather
vociferous about them
now there were some indications that
biden wanted to make it quite clear from
the outset that there was a
deep religious element in this
whole issue yes he's very much into
how the religion has been playing his
view on things so he made sure that the
media knew
that he was taking part in a activity
that reflected his roman catholic faith
if he becomes president you'll only be
the second
roman catholic president in the history
of the united states
the first one was assassinated as we
said jfk
yes and according to many many sources
it is probable that the jesuits were
involved even in that okay but
that is of course now all in the realms
of conspiracy
so we'll leave it at that but
he made that famous speech about
separation of church and state
and there were people that were very
upset about that
and in one of the previous elections
there were candidates
that quite blatantly said that kennedy's
speech
made them want to throw up yes correct
right yeah and they were candidates for
the presidency of the united states
i wonder what joe biden would say
and whether he wants to play that same
role
i doubt it i doubt it i think
prophetically we're too far down the
line
so remember the kings of the world are
going to give their
power unto the beast and everybody must
know
who the beast is yes and he's very much
part of the beast
in fact he's a member of the beast's
religious system yeah so let's have a
look at this little video
and see what we can glean from it
on his first full day as president-elect
joe biden did what is for him at the
core of his life
a mass at the church where his first
wife son
and daughter are buried his religious
faith as america knows
guides their next president
[Applause]
it was on a stage in his hometown of
wilmington with a nation watching
that he and his vice president-elect
have presented themselves as america's
future
and healing division means reaching out
to those who supported the man he beat
the election of kamala harris a woman
and a woman of color to the white house
is a first that is hugely significant
for this country
while i may be the first woman in this
office
i will not be the last because every
little girl
watching tonight sees that this
is a country of possibilities
they were listening all over the country
not least on the streets outside the
white house
celebrations among those yearning an end
to the trump hero
the sitting president headed for the
golf course again he'd spent his sunday
morning tweeting
he continues to allege election fraud
while providing little evidence
twitter keeps adding the warnings it is
likely to end up in the courts
and republicans who are no allies of
trump don't expect him to go quietly
we're not going to change president
trump or his nature uh
in the waning days of the presidency and
so
i i don't think i'm going to be giving
him advice as to what to do the
president is going to do
what he has traditionally done what he's
doing now i don't think that's going to
be a surprise for anybody
but joe biden's not waiting for donald
trump his administration has already
launched a new website the transition
team is working
and tomorrow they'll unveil their own
coronavirus task force
joe biden knows the celebrations are
over and this is a country in crisis
joe biden has urged his supporters to
keep the faith whatever challenges to
his legitimacy he faces
he's achieved his ultimate political
goal and the hard work
is only just beginning first point to
ponder
he wants the nation to know about his
faith yes
and he makes no bones about it this is
in total contrast
to what jfk did yeah jfk made it quite
clear
that no catholic will dictate to the
president
what he should do and no protestant
prelate
would dictate to the president as to
what he should do
there will be absolute separation
now donald trump laid the groundwork
for the fusion yeah he did he got rid of
the johnson amendment
he did many things to bring the voice of
the clergy to the fore
yes the whole spiritual advisory board
that he brought
one could always almost say that the way
has been prepared
for the kings of the world to give their
power
unto the beast isn't that correct yep so
there's a vast contrast there
and he seems to have support romney
seems to be quite supportive and quite
pleased that the previous era is gone
so speculatively
we could say that the thesis antithesis
is working very well yes working very
well
if it should reverse in the future well
that will be very interesting
yes but let's see how this pans out
now donald trump had a huge support
amongst the evangelicals yes and then
towards
the end of his presidency there was a
swing
a swing away towards biden
and the guardian reported on the 9th of
october already this was before the
election of course
that faith leaders back biden in sign
that evangelical support for trump
is waning so already before the election
there was this support
shift yes from the one to the other
right
and more than 1 600 faith leaders in the
united states have publicly backed joe
biden
the democratic candidate in next month's
presidential election
well that's history now yep what about
the roman catholic church itself
remember that he had tremendous support
that is now trump
yes from the conservative arm of the
roman catholic church
but not from the liberal no not at all
so now
and and by the way they were calling
this liberal arm
actually part of the swamp right yes yes
vegano
yes he's calling it but we'll come to
that because we have to look at the
whole
prophetic picture always bear in mind
thesis
antithesis synthesis
and the world has to run with the
synthesis
and revelation chapter 13 tells us
that the second beast of revelation 13
which is the united states of america
will lead the way in bringing the world
to accepting the mark of the beast
and he made it quite clear biden that
he and the united states once again
wants to be the example for the world
which they should emulate yes
so what did he do this first day or the
first went to church and he made it very
public that he's taking part in a mass
and he wants everybody to see
that he is a roman catholic and he never
made a speech about separation of church
and state
yeah and they want to downplay trump
going
on the sunday playing golf that's right
now i want to know what his views are
unfortunately they've been very
forthcoming
they have been very open with their
views
so that makes it even more interesting
yes let us
continue this statement is rather
interesting this record-breaking group
of endorsers shows that presidents trump
lack of kindness and decency
is energizing faith communities and will
cost him this election
said doug paggett executive director of
the christian campaign
organization vote
common good that's interesting right
which compiled the endorsements
and there was a group called pro-life
evangelicals for biden
they didn't agree with biden's stance on
abortion yes but but they like this
openness
and then the last month more than 150
catholic theologians activists and nuns
signed an open letter to catholic voters
urging them to oppose
trump saying that he flouts core values
at the heart
of catholic social teaching
social teaching is becoming a very
important issue yes not obedience to god
obedience to roman catholic social
doctrine and we had a whole discussion
on that
and rerum novarum and all those
encyclicals
another very important point of course
is that
so many of these prophets in the
evangelical world were so convinced
yes that trump would win we showed quite
a few videos of it as well
and they're hoping that it will still
take place
and they're saying this is all fraud and
it will take place he will win
but if he does not it will say a lot for
the prophets because the bible clearly
says that if the word of the prophet
doesn't come true then do not be afraid
of him right
correct so let's have a look at what
some of
the people that were so convinced and
even spoke
in tongues in order to ensure that it
would take place
what they have to say on the issue
surely the lord god does nothing
nothing without revealing his
purpose to his servants the prophets
and i have been interviewing prophet
after prophet that i trust
that has been saying without blinking an
eye
donald trump will have two terms
president trump is going to win and you
know what
the way god built me when i hear a word
from god
you can't get me off of that right now
if i hear a word for myself then i'll
i'll be double-minded but if i hear a
word from god
there's nothing you can do to talk me
out of it
it's not just prophets that are saying
he's going to have a second term
sid they're experts saying they're
people that have
reliable track records that are saying
look
you need to understand what's going on
here this thing is not over
this thing has not been decided we
dodged a bullet ladies and gentlemen we
dodged a bullet
the democrat plan big tech's plan
the liberal media's plan was to uproot
the american
system and put another system in place
that monster would have still been there
if it was kept
underground through a trump victory
this forcing it into the court is
causing an
investigation to uncover corruption that
we never imagined
they this is a moment of god's reprieve
and mercy on the united states and i
think we're going to
understand later you know the day of the
election sid
i woke up and the holy spirit said
something's going to happen tonight that
you're not ready for i said lord what is
it
it's not going to turn out like you
think and when you do
see it don't be shaken because there's
going to be a surprise
and to me a portion of the surprise at
this moment
is that we have uncovered a layer of
corruption
that is beyond anything we could have
imagined probably one of the
sharpest prophets i know it keeps
calling me
and telling me i keep hearing only one
word about president trump and the word
that god
keeps speaking to me is vindicated
vindicated vindicated i get excited when
i say that mario
you know and here's the other part that
you look at god how he puts the pieces
together
you know amy coney barrett was one of
the lead attorneys
in florida in the year 2000 during the
jed i didn't know that she was there in
florida that was one of her cases
she already understands voter fraud she
understands this
and she's in the supreme court under the
wire
this is a monster movie ladies and
gentlemen we're going to see the glory
of god fall on the united states i have
no doubt of it
well the prophets haven't given up on
their prophecy right
nope and they are expecting
great upheavals now
i don't know whether these prophets
necessarily
understand prophecy and
what the lord has told us in the book of
revelation
and where we are heading we are heading
for a time of trouble such
as never was yeah
now somehow there must be a contingency
even in the enemy's side i'm talking
about the enemy of god
to prepare humanity for
this tremendous upheaval that is coming
upon society
right correct he must have an
explanation yeah
people will say why is this happening
why are all of these calamities coming
upon
us and eventually they will say why are
these plagues falling yes
because they are so convinced that they
are in the right
so is there a plan within a plan
to set up the system that will
eventually
enforce the mark of the peace but at the
same time
plant the seed for the coming calamities
or
to give an explanation for the coming
calamities that are coming upon the
earth
definitely so we've already seen that
many of these prophets without this
prophecy coming true or not coming true
it's irrelevant
that they have been wrong they've said
this will happen on this date and it
never happened this will happen then and
it never happened
and we already know that they're wrong
they don't have to prove themselves for
another time
but even if they should prove themselves
to be correct on this issue
they would still be wrong on the over
all prophecy yes correct
so this is the other aspect yeah so
let's just paint the picture here is a
president-elect
that is saying quite plainly what his
religious
view is and that he wants to integrate
his religious view with these policies
yes which is the opposite of what jfk
did
and then there are people that say no
this is the deep state
this is apostasy this is liberalism this
is
uh you know the monster the monster
there's this whole thing that
has to speak this as they're talking
about
bring onto the cards that everybody can
see what conspiracy is going on
and perversions and there are so many
stories out there
we should not be sidelined by any of
them we just have to look at the
prophetic scenario that's all we're
interested in
now sid roth is not the only one
who has been you know prophesying about
a trump victory
there are others as well right yes and
there's an interesting one on cbn news
where some of the people are talking
about these issues too let's look at
that one too just
for the sake of completeness
trump will be president no matter what
you hear
author and prophet kat kerr told the
elijah list steve schultz
that the prophets did not get it wrong
she says god is getting ready to uncover
corruption
and evil she says it will be a landslide
of exposure it will start with a phone
call and i can tell you
you will be shocked to see how much
exposure comes from that
but trump will win he will be president
of the united states he will sit in that
office for four more years
and god will have his way in this
country kerr is not alone
prophet jeremiah johnson believes before
trump is declared the winner
joe biden may prematurely announce that
he
is the next president of the united
states he wrote to his followers quote
either a lying spirit has filled the
mouths of numerous trusted prophetic
voices in america
or donald j trump really has won the
presidency
and we are witnessing a diabolical and
evil plan
unfold to steal the election at 4 30
the lord said to me i am going to give
your president a second win
[Music]
just a few weeks ago pastor denise
goulet spoke those words over president
trump
while he attended the international
church of las vegas
she joined a chorus of other prophetic
voices that believe
god told them trump will win including
cbn's pat robertson i want to say
without question
trump is going to win the election
christian prayer leader lou engle says
it's not
time to despair but rather for the
church to pray like esther
and that corruption and voter fraud be
exposed
expose exposed that's what happened to
haman
a three-day esther fast and then a
scene is brought forth where literally
literally esther exposes haman
and a sudden reversal takes place in the
book of amos chapter 3 verse 7
it says god does nothing without
revealing his plans to his servants
the prophets and these prophetic voices
say
it ain't over
well what do you say it ain't over it
really seems
it is the most interesting election
we've ever watched in our lifetimes at
least
me and my lifetime it's a little longer
than yours it actually it
doesn't seem like an election i don't
know it's
something biblical yeah it's something
biblical and
it's it's theatrical yeah yes
so very fascinating but uh
we're still heading towards the plan yes
this was the evangelical side
so how do the conservative catholics
feel about it
the same they say i mean the liberal
catholics on biden's side they're on
biden's side let's just look at the
liberal catholics
well here is the statement issued by
archbishop
jose gomez of los angeles and president
of the u.s conference of catholic
bishops so this is a high-ranking man
and he had this to say we thank god for
the blessings of
liberty the american people have spoken
in this election
now is the time for our leaders to come
together in a spirit of
national unity and to commit themselves
to
dialogue and compromise for the common
good what does that sound like synthesis
[Laughter]
that sounds like synthetic for the
common good
compromise yes common good you might as
well have put those words in there
it's time for synthesis yeah absolutely
let's continue we asked the blessed
virgin mary
by the way where is the blessed virgin
mary she's asleep in the grave she's
asleep in the grave so who are they
asking but let leave at that
we ask the blessed virgin mary patroness
of
this great nation to intercede for us
may she help us to work together to
fulfill the beautiful vision of
america's
missionaries and founders one nation
under god where the sanctity of every
human life is defended and freedom of
conscience
and religion are guaranteed
there is an anti-abortion statement
built into this
and synthesis will require the adoption
thereof right
correct so this is a public statement
and it has some very roman catholic
elements in it now how does the biden
camp
and the vatican fit together yes are
there a better match
than the trump vatican yes
absolutely definitely but as we saw
that most of the administration of the
trump campaign
was roman catholic correct so
the only way you can explain that is
with theseus antithesis synthesis 100
so and also king of the north south
sitting at the same table absolutely
let's just have a look
at some other issues pope francis
this comes from march to 2016.
but we put it in there because biden's
going to refer to this issue right
correct
then it was said that pope francis
world's most popular leader
but he is the most popular leader pope
francis is more popular than
any political world leader according to
a new opinion poll
the poll puts him 11 points ahead of his
closest
rival president barack obama in terms of
popularity
that was under the biden obama
obama campbell which biden was a part
right here is an
interview that joe biden had with the
jesuits
we always like to talk about that
connection this is not a conspiracy by
the way
this is news exactly and uh detractors
will have to look at the news and not
jump onto the conspiracy bandwagon
100 we're not saying this they're saying
it themselves they're saying it
themselves so
let's have a look at this
[Music]
mr vice president thank you very much
for being with us today i'm flattered to
be invited father exactly
at least two of your predecessors as
vice president john adams
and thomas jefferson um it's well known
among historians they were not big fans
of the jesuits
now a mere 50 years ago we had a debate
in this country about whether
a catholic could actually be elected
president should be elected president
we established diplomatic relations
between the u.s and the vatican only in
the 1980s
and now this jesuit pope is coming to
address a
joint session of congress what does that
say about our country
look father um i think it's sort of the
history of the journey of this country
if you think about it it's always been
in the direction
of inclusiveness it's always been in the
direction
of of uh acceptance it's always been an
injection
in the direction of expanding um
rights and recognizing differences and
and i think whether it's a civil rights
movement whether it's the attitude
toward the catholic church whether it's
the attitude toward minorities
it's a it's a constant progression i
think it
makes what makes america the unique
country in the world it's about policy
it's about
it's about uh the whole idea of anything
is possible
and it's about progression and i know
that sounds um
maybe that sounds too uh nativist that i
i'm
so proud but it really is who we are
you know look in not too distant future
father we're going to be a uh
caucasians of european descent are going
to be an absolute minority in the united
states of america
and it's a reflection of our uh
of who we are and it's so it's not at
all surprising
and that will change the face not only
of the country but of the church in this
country well
it will change the face of the church
and by the way uh
you and i both know it's not i shouldn't
be interviewing you but you know there
are some uh
real uh um differences within the church
in terms of uh
the uh tone and direction and uh
and just how uh how far we should reach
out the thing i love about this pope
i got to meet him when i went to his uh
quote inauguration i always thought it
was an installation but
the inauguration and i had the great
pleasure of representing the united
states of america
my sister was with me and i sat in the
altar and afterwards as you know father
you line up an alphabetical order in the
basilica and the holy father stands at
the foot of the altar and
greets every head of state or acting
headed or though acting for the head of
state
united states for at the very end and so
i walked up and there was a
wonderful irish monsignor who had sat in
with me in a long interview
that or discussion i had with pope
benedict just several months earlier
and he turned he said oh mr vice
president he said
he said you know holy father
and the pope reached out like this and
he grabbed my hand he said
i know mr vice president you're always
welcome here that is the message he sent
into the world
that and that is the tone he's striking
everywhere absolutely he's that's why
he's the single most popular figure
in the world today and not just in
catholic nations
across the board and it's because of the
you know he he's the embodiment of
catholic social doctrine that i was
raised with right the idea that
everyone's entitled to dignity that the
poor
the poor should be given special
preference that
you have an obligation uh to uh to reach
out and be inclusive that
i mean look look at the encyclical on cl
on climate change it's all about you
know
we have responsibilities uh we have to
husband this
this planet i mean and i i'm excited
quite frankly as a practicing catholic i
am really excited by
the whole world is getting to see what
are the
basic essential elements of what
constitutes
catholicism right we can argue about
dogma we can
argue about some of the defeated
doctrine has been declared
but this is this is below it and above
it this is something much larger
well is it for catholic social
doctrine one hundred percent is he for
low data c yes very staunch
very staunch i wonder whether that uh in
embraces also the sunday issue which is
in that document
100 percent so he's talking about
catholicism and what it is all about
and what a wonderful example to the
world
and pope francis the most popular man in
the
entire world and he's the embodiment
of catholic social doctrine absolutely
and then the latest encyclical which he
doesn't refer to here of course because
it wasn't written at that stage
but this is his philosophy
and this never came to the fall until
now
correct all right now we've seen what
the
the liberal catholic view is let's have
a look at the conservative
catholic view because you always have to
contrast the two right there's a reason
why
they both exist yes there must be
because the devil surely isn't divided
is it definitely not no so let's have a
look at this
it's not over for trump i know people
are getting discouraged out there
they saw cnn say something fake news
they saw a bunch of people stand out in
front of the white house so what
so what remember
way back in the day when it al gore he
didn't concede till december
this thing is going to go on and on we
have
saved the steel rallies all over the
country we got the jericho marches at
all the state capitals
first ones were yesterday the big one
started today
noon what is the jericho march
you'll remember in the old testament
joshua led the people of israel for
seven days
around the city of jericho on the
seventh day they lapped the city of
jericho seven times they blew their
horns
they cried out to god and the walls came
tumbling down not by might
of man but by the word of god and look
what they're holding there the ark of
the covenant
we catholics believe that in the new
testament the ark of the new covenant
the new testament is the blessed virgin
mary the holy theotokos because in the
old testament
the ark of the covenant contained
the word of god on stone the ten
commandments our lady
contained the word of god made flesh
the perfect law keeper the son of god
the son of man himself
so this is what we're going to do go to
every capital especially the swing state
capitol
at the capitol building on every day at
noon
today sunday go to church of course mass
is more important
monday tuesday wednesday we're gonna
show up
and we're going to lap every capital
seven times we're gonna pray
and i've invited you to bring statues of
our lady
icons crucifixes crosses
t-shirts everything you can to take up
space
for god and to pray and
intercede it's not over you know cnn
is really just a bunch of people
who have cameras here's what we're going
to do
we're going to pray our rosary every day
like we always do we're going to up it
maybe
10 decades 15 decades and then i want
everyone going if you live proximate
to a state capital i want you to go to a
jericho march
they form at 11 45 every single day
in your local time zone and then they
start at noon
and you go around the capitol building
seven times praying
now there are other denominations and
other sex there and i
i talked to the people who who are
involved in this there is no by the way
there's no one asking for money there's
no
uh jerichomarch.com these are just
people coming together to pray
but i said look i don't want to send
catholics out there if they're going to
have
you know fundamentalists or charismatics
yelling at them about the rosary
or whatever they say no this is like the
march for life
you go to the capitol and you walk
around with your group you find the
catholics they're the people holding the
rosaries by the way
you find the catholics and you group up
with them and you know maybe
60 70 yards in front of you is a group
of i don't know
evangelicals or charismatics i even
heard there were some
some jews out there you don't have to
be part of what they're doing you find
your group of people
and you do what you're doing which is
praying the rosary
singing the the catholic hymns etc so
that's what the jericho march is going
to be i want you to spread it on
facebook
and we i told y'all this beforehand we
all knew
that the democrats would never concede
we knew that they would try to cheat
there's even that clip of biden saying
they have the biggest fraud
uh organized fraud ever
we knew they were going to cheat we knew
they lied to us all during covet
about numbers they created a hype
they tried to destroy the economy we
knew they weren't going to concede
we knew they were going to cheat and we
knew we weren't going to have the
election
results on november 3rd we all knew that
and now
people are freaking out we knew that
we've been talking about that
well the catholics the conservative
catholics seem as convinced as
the prophets right and they're not
giving up
and they're going on jericho marches and
they're going to
march around waiting for the swamp
system
to finally collapse and this kingdom
power to come through
so whether they get their wish or
whether they don't get their wish
is really irrelevant prophecy is going
to be fulfilled
the kings of the world are going to give
their power unto the beast
yes and the whole world is going to
follow
and these people refuse to accept
what has happened and they're hoping for
this
final overthrow now some of them are a
little bit
more contemplative
and archbishop vegano he has said
that he also of course is a trump fan
as you know yes and he has said that
this might be part of the chastisement
that is coming
so we need to look at that aspect
because remember
there has to be a contingency
preparation
for what is coming upon the world it
can't all be peace and safety if the
bible says there's going to be calamity
right
so let's have a look at the next issues
but uh besides that
this is basically idolatry right
yes he even said bring your idols bring
your idols with you and
pray the rosary the bible is very clear
that we shouldn't have
repetitive prayer and the rosary
consists of ten hail marys one our
father
ten el marys one our father etc
so and what is also interesting is that
he mentioned
there will be other denominations also
at this jericho mars
agenda all doing this seven times
walking around the
state building is religion a very
prominent
feature in this election absolutely
never before like this
exactly unbelievable
breaking news from archbishop carlo
maria vegano who has given a new
interview
to the italian daily newspaper il
giornale
and in it he has asked the question what
would happen if biden is elected and
trump loses the election
but here's what he says very
interestingly if
trump were to lose the election he says
what scenarios await
catholics uh of the world if trump
should lose that's the questions he's
asked
and he responds this way if trump loses
the presidential elections the final
catholic con
that's the withholder will fail that's a
reference to 2 thessalonians 2
6 to 7 which you should look up it
refers to the end of times
and he says the catholic con will fail
that which prevents the mystery of
iniquity from revealing itself
and the dictatorship of the new world
order which has already won
bergoglio over to its cause will have an
ally
in the new american president joe biden
does not have his own identity
he is only the expression of a power
that does not dare reveal itself
for what it truly is and that is
hiding itself behind a person who is
totally incapable of holding the office
of the president of the united states
also because of his weakened mental
capabilities
but it is precisely in his weakness for
pending complaints
in his ability to be blackmailed for
conflicts of interest
that biden reveals himself as a
marionette
maneuvered by the elites a puppet in the
hands
of people thirsting for power and ready
to do anything to expand it
archbishop vegeta continues again
talking about what would happen if trump
lost the election and biden won
he says we would find ourselves facing
an orwellian dictatorship
desired by both the deep state and the
deep church
in which the rights that today are
considered fundamental and
inalienable would be trampled upon with
the complicity of mainstream media
i want to emphasize he continues that
the universal religion desired by the
united nations and freemasonry
has active collaborators at the highest
level of the catholic church who usurp
authority
and adulterate the magisterium they are
opposing the mystical body of christ
which is mankind's only ark of salvation
with the mystical body of antichrist
according to the prophecy of venerable
archbishop fulton sheen ecumenism
malthusianism environmentalism
pansexualism
and immigrationism are the new dogmas of
this universal religion
whose ministers are preparing the advent
of the antichrist
prior to the final persecution and the
definitive
victory of our lord but just as the
glorious resurrection of the savior was
preceded
by his passion and death so too is the
church
journeying towards her own calvary as
and just as the sanhedrin
thought that it would eliminate the
messiah by crucifying him
so the infam infamous sect
believes that the eclipse of the church
is a prelude to its end
a tiny remnant remains says the
archbishop
made of fervent catholics just as the
mother of god
saint john and mary magdalene remained
at the foot of the cross
well that was the view of the archbishop
there are many many interesting features
in that view
and it is very closely aligned
also to the fatima visions
yeah because the chastisement that would
come upon the church when it
became an apostate institution
run by freemasonry and the deep state
and not by the ark which we heard
previously
was mary right
now he referred to second thessalonians
so let's just take
ii thessalonians and see what he was
referring to
and in actual fact this is a
prophecy concerning the antichrist
and we we've looked at this on many
occasions
and the reformers were all of one accord
yes
that this applied to the papacy
we read from ii thessalonians chapter
two
from verse one he referred to
verse 6 but we'll get to that
now we beseech you brethren by the
coming of our lord jesus christ and by
our gathering together unto him
that ye be not soon shaken in mind or be
troubled
neither by spirit nor by word nor by
letter as from
us as that day of christ
is at hand let no man deceive you by any
means
for that day shall not come except there
come a falling away first
and that man of sin be revealed the son
of perdition
yes now the reformers claimed
that this referred to the roman catholic
system
so paul said the coming of the lord is
not at hand yet
first there must come the falling away
then he continued
who opposeth and exalters himself above
all that is called god
or that is worshipped so that he
as god sitteth in the temple of god
showing himself that he is god
now again the reformers were of one
accord
that this was a reference to the papacy
and that book that we referred to last
time romanism and the reformation makes
it
absolutely crystal clear what they
believe yes
he said that this temple that they're
talking about is not a temple of stone
but he's the church because paul
referred to the church
yes as the temple of the living god so
here
is the man of sin sitting in the church
pretending that he is god
assuming the title of god yes and we've
shown
numerous times not only who that belongs
to
not only as he laid claim to it but he
has
laid claim to it in practice by
proclaiming
a law contrary to god's law correct
remember ye not that when i was yet with
you
i told you these things now remember
paul is speaking here and
the the authority of the roman empire
and it was illegal to speak against the
emperor
yes so he is referring to something he
told them in
private but he's not going to put it in
writing yeah
and then he comes to this verse that the
archbishop referred to
or the cardinal and now ye know
what withholdeth that he might be
revealed
in his time and what was it
that he revealed was withholding now if
you go to the early church fathers they
were all
crystal clear on the issue and i had a
whole lecture on it at one stage with
all the quotes
they believed that what was withholding
this roman power
this papal power from coming into power
was pagan rome
yeah and once pagan rome had fallen
then the road would be opened for the
rise
of papal rome that's what the reformers
believed that's what the church fathers
believed
so they are applying this to a
futuristic antichrist and it's not
biblical correct you have to go back to
the source
and then he quite plainly says for the
mystery of iniquity
does already work that was in paul's day
it was already beginning this attempt to
fuse paganism yes and christianity
and simon magus was very instrumental
in doing that the gnosticism side is it
yes
and he already worked only he who now
letteth will let until he be taken out
of the way
so pagan rome was in the way for this
fusion
it had to go and make room for paper
wrong
that's what the bible says these people
are of course
confusing the issue but there's a double
plan here
vigano said that if biden wins
the deep state and the deep church
will finally be ruling
and that only a remnant which he calls
catholic will remain now the bible says
the remnant is those that keep the
commandments of god
and hold to the testament obviously they
cannot be the remnant because they don't
hold to the commandments of god they
hold to the commandments of the church
so here at the fatima center i found
this discussion very interesting because
it relates to this
chastisement that vigano was referring
to
here they're saying that rome has
deviated
pope francis they're referring to his
statement
about accepting uh same-sex marriage
same-sex marriages but again let's just
qualify that
he never took a stand doctrinally
no he never sat on the bishop's chair
and said that this is perfectly
acceptable
correct you must understand roman
catholic yeah
he never did that no if if he says it
anywhere else
it's his opinion it's it's just an
opinion
and he never made a decision he
brushed it off and handed it over to the
state
and said you take care of that issue he
never made an excuted draw statement so
they cannot
really say this but it's interesting to
me
that in their discussion they referred
to
this as part of the law of god yeah
because he made them male and female and
you cannot change god's law
now that's interesting uh
if you cannot change god's law have they
looked at the ten commandments and now
they have been changed
yeah exactly so let's have a look at
this little discussion
[Music]
christos vincit christus regnat christus
imperat hello i'm david rodriguez from
the fatima center
and today i'd like to invite you to just
a little
casual conversation that catholics are
having all over the world
after sunday mass as we all know this
past week
uh pope francis has dropped a you know
bombshell
into the media world everybody's talking
about it and so we thought
just like here at our parish people will
be talking about it i've invited
some gentlemen to have a casual frank
conversation that faithful catholics are
probably having all over the world
with some confusion with some you know
concern
but i'd like to welcome mr ken shannon
mr tom dowler
and mr bob houston gentlemen thanks for
coming
as you know uh it seems to many people
certainly from what you know the new
york times and the washington post and
every other media outlet all over the
world
not just in the states but you know
everywhere is saying
that uh the church is changing her
stance two thousand your stance and that
uh with pope francis now in this uh
informal documentary francesco that was
released
in rome this past week played at the
vatican gardens
he is uh endorsing a kind of civil union
or some sort of legal structure
so that those who are living according
to an unnatural vice
according to a lifestyle that is uh
condemned by natural law by god's
eternal law
but that should be permitted and that
they should have some kind of uh
you know legitimacy i guess to these
unions and
obviously that's that's difficult
because it has caused i think a lot of
concern
and confusion for catholics everywhere
uh as i see it i mean it's it's almost
twofold i'm seeing
it one is in one sense it's very simple
because catholic teaching is crystal
clear
uh so i just put up a little write-up on
the fatima center's website in fact
where i mentioned
you know natural law is natural law
god's law is eternal it isn't flexible
it doesn't change and so no one no one
can change that as i mentioned i say
no pope bishop priest no king no
president no congress
i mean no angel or devil no authority in
the world
can change that
well we're not going to play the whole
video they're having a discussion about
whether the pope has the power to change
the teaching of the church
for two thousand years which has been
held for them by 2000 years
but i found it interesting and i thought
it was noteworthy
that he said no pope no government
no legislative not even the angels awful
angel
can change god's law it's immutable
and does he not know that they changed
god's law
that they removed the second that they
they changed the fourth commandment that
they split the tenth one into two
that they changed the order i mean it's
incredible isn't it correct
and yet they themselves have said
you cannot change god's law so really
they shot themselves on the foot
but what i was really referring to there
is
that he also referred to another
visionary
that said that this was part of the
decay of the church
now i have a book here
and it's called the thunder of justice
it appeared quite a number of years ago
and i actually did a lecture
signs and wonders where i discussed many
of the issues
in that are raised in this book so i'll
put a link in
yes put a link in it's always a good
idea that people can get a better idea
of what is happening
now why would this book appear
where all these catholic visionaries had
uh confrontations with an apparition of
mary
fatima of course playing a very
essential role
being almost the mother institute
and then you had all the other ones
lassiette etc etc majidori
and what had been predicted a time of
great turmoil
a time of great distress
the devil knows that there is a time of
great distress coming
he has to prepare the minds for it and
he has to divert the mind from the
real issue yes which is an attack on
the authority of god and the authority
of god
so i thought i'd just browse through
one of the chapters quickly here
and this is what bishop vigano was
referring to and what these people were
discussing at the fatima center
this is chapter 13 interesting number
smoke enters the church talking about
the roman catholic church
and it says as we have seen it appears
that information about
this apostasy was contained in the
unrevealed third secret of fatima
this third secret was never made in
public
they said it was about john paul being
shot but
they don't really buy that one at last
la salette france the blessed mother on
september 19 1846
appeared to melanie calvert and maximum
girard
mary told melanie in the year 1864
that luther together with a large
number of demons will be
unloosed from hell
and will put an end to faith little by
little
even in those dedicated to god
so this is a reference within the roman
catholic church
now we know that mary is asleep
therefore this was not mary that ever
appeared
because according to the scripture she
has nothing to do
under the sun and will be sleeping until
the resurrection right
yes and then
rome will lose the faith and become the
seat of the antichrist
that's interesting very very this is
exactly what
vegan has been referring exactly now
do you find it strange that this man is
not
being publicly reprimanded by
the bishops of rome he's
saying exactly just what he wants
against the pope
but nothing else nothing happens yes
for now is the time of all times the end
of
all ends the church will be in eclipse
the world
will be in dismay
and then it continues for behold the age
of ages the end the extremity is at hand
the church passes into
darkness the world will be in a state of
consternation
perplexity and confusion now you don't
have to be a prophet to know that you
just have to read your bible
correct but you have to give an
explanation yeah
because what if people really start
believing the bible they will see what
the problem is so we need a diversion
yeah
okay at the time of the end
these apparitions the church was under
siege from the adherence of
false philosophical systems the
freemasons
associated secret societies
and the state is this what uh vigano
sounds exactly the same he's reading
from the script right
now here's an interesting one
pope pius the ninth in 1846
in his syllable of heiress pronounced
the solemn condemnation of the erroneous
propositions
of the modern philosophy secret
societies
and communism now everybody has referred
to
the biden camp as being very
communistically inclined
yeah especially the extreme left
right so these are issues
that are very important the church was
aware of the seductive power of
communism
and published other encyclicals
condemning it pope
leo the 13th in 1884 in his encyclical
humanum genos exposed and condemned the
propositions of freemasons
the affiliated secret societies and the
philosophy of masons which he
identified as naturalism
i find it fascinating that many of these
bishops were of course part of
freemasonry
while all these things were happening
and then there were the visions of
father goby
and he reported on august 26
1983 error is being taught
and propagated beneath the ambiguous
formulas of a new
cultural interpretation of the truth
this is what vigano is
accusing pope francis of so you have
this
interesting division they are preparing
another church
once separated from the pope and this
will cause a further scandal
that of a sorrowful division
it talks about ecclesiastical
masonry and then the blessed
mother warned father goby
on november 15 1919 how
great is your responsibility oh pastors
of the holy church of god
you continue along the path of division
from the pope
and the rejection of his magisterium
vegano used the exact terminology
correct
indeed in a hidden way there is in
preparation
a true schism which could soon become
open and proclaimed are we there yep
absolutely 100 and then
there will remain only a small faithful
remnant
did he say that exactly the same words
over which i will keep watch in the
garden of
my immaculate hearts
the great trial has arrived for all
humanity
the chastisement predicted by me at
fatima
then we have the connection and
contained
in that part of the secret which has not
yet been revealed
that's the antichrist that's why we had
fatima in there
is about to take place
so when is it going to take place when
this great
schism becomes public has it become
public
yes are you sure yep absolutely that's
what they're saying
is this a conspiracy or is this news
this is news we're just
you're reading from there and showing it
in the news
isn't this amazing the great
moment of divine justice and mercy has
come upon the world
i believe this is the most interesting
election that we've ever seen
and should biden become the next
president
of the united states it would fit
perfectly
with the script yes that the schism must
come the antichrist must be revealed
he must rule and there must be turmoil
upon the earth like you cannot believe
and the christian world will look at
jerusalem
and wait for the antichrist to make his
appearance
in a physical temple built of stone yes
when the bible and the reformers were
actually
absolutely clear that the turmoil is
right here in the church
yes the not the physical bolt with stone
and the chaos that we see can explain
why we're having the chastisement
why there are so many calamities why
the world is falling falling apart and
that's how they can get the synthesis
absolutely and eventually because of the
great turmoil that arises
they will have a lever in their hand and
they will be able
to say it is because you have departed
from the true faith let us return
let us do what we need to do and who is
the enemy
the commandment keeping people of god
they are the ones that will not go along
with it yeah
if byron wins it's interesting
then you can he will bring in all sorts
different parts that to bring the
synthesis like the climate change
absolutely he's been saying that the
sunday legislation is in there so
you've got the religious sunday and the
secular sunday and the interesting thing
is
when they bring in that legislation
things on earth will not get better
and worse yes because then the plagues
are going to correct they say
there will be peace and there will be no
peace no peace and the plagues are
suddenly falling and they're supposedly
doing what is right
so where's the problem those people that
didn't want to
go along yes and they have a reason
why there is such a calamity because
fatima apparently proclaimed it
but they could have just read it in the
bible right yeah
so let's see what will happen according
to the scriptures
revelation 19 verse 19 and i saw the
beast
that's roman catholicism and the kings
of the earth
that's the rulers of the world and their
armies
gathered together to make war against
him that sat on the horse and against
his army now can you make a physical war
against god
no so they are gathered together to
have a spiritual war against god right
they're going to attack god's
commandments and they're going to attack
god's people yes and they're going to
use their military
in order to do that to enforce their
dogmas
but then there's the good news and the
beast was taken
and with him the false prophet
so roman catholicism together
with fallen protestantism
that wrought miracles before him with
which he deceived them that
had received the mark of the beast and
them that worshipped his image
these both were cast alive into the lake
of fire burning with brimstone
and the remnant was slain with the sword
of him that sat upon the horse which
sword proceeded out of his mouth and all
the fowls were filled with their flesh
this is the true outcome of this
conflict
they have this vision of the remnant
finally rising and being
in full control of the entire world yes
it will not happen nope the whole system
will be destroyed the same with the
stone that comes loose in daniel and
destroys
the whole system so it will be the same
my brother for those who
see a biden victory as a time of
reprieve
i think we have news for them this sets
the stage
for what is about to happen upon the
world
and you have the conservative catholics
shouting
and you have the evangelicals shouting
and you have the so-called deep state
and masonry
and new world order doing their thing
introducing legislation they have a
reason
for the calamities that are coming upon
the earth their eyes are fixed on
jerusalem
and in the meantime nobody notices
that they have set up a system which
makes avoid the god
the word of god and the law of god may
god give
us wisdom as we approach the next
four years amen amen let's pray heavenly
father
what a fascinating part of history has
just played off before our very eyes
where in all the elements that are given
to us
in the book of revelation are portrayed
before the eyes of humanity in the media
for all to see
and lord yet there are so few
that will actually see where this is
heading
help us to make the word of god our
guide
and not what this prophet says and that
prophet says
but what does the word of god say let
that be
our guide is my prayer in jesus name
amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you